if a skill is master it become
automatized anything
that become automatized can be done
without the conscious thought of how one
is performing the activity hi i am
muhammad sanlee a 13 year old student in
8th grade from a young age i had a
passion in emerging technologies
and science data science compares
mathematics statistics and computer
science when i was nine my father used
to take me to the construction sites and
he observed that i looked at
construction site meticulously paying
careful attention on every minute detail
and slowly i started identifying
construction errors my father saw this
and he told me i can do good at
construction and it taught me all the
ins and outs of civil engineering then i
got interested in mechanical electrical
electronics and computer science i want
to gain a professional learning
experience
so i decided to enroll myself to simply
learn
master program on october 2019 uh two
years back i started teaching civil
mechanical electrical electronics and
computer engineers designing and
programming till date i have taught more
than 5 000 engineers and i do not charge
any fees from my students
as my purpose is to motivate students
towards learning uh i consider this as
an act of gratitude towards god learning
process with simple learn was very
smooth and i could understand critical
topics like data science with r and
python the entrepreneurs are
knowledgeable and they make critical
topics sound simple practice practice
practice and obedience to teachers and
parents learn the explicit knowledge
build tacit skills always keep assessing
learning applying and adapting this will
help you position yourself competitively
so you can do meaningful work for a long
time to come